out of the crisis on our southern border
vice president harris still taking heat
for a trip to el paso texas on friday
new critics this weekend are faulting
her for not visiting the epicenter of
the crisis
that happens to be hundreds of miles of
war away in the rio grande valley
and for taking three months to go to the
border in the first place
she says she is focusing on the roots of
the crisis which is why she went to
guatemala and mexico city
meanwhile officials say the migrant
surge is not letting up
despite the scorching heat that has
already caused some deaths of migrants
and the other dangers they face
alex hogan live now on the border in
mission texas
which is in the rio grande valley area
that's where the
bulk of the migrants that we have been
seeing arriving
in our country here asking for asylum
and also giving themselves up the bulk
of them
uh have appeared alex is standing by uh
near what has been
part of the old fence hi alex
hi eric that's right this is part of the
unfinished border wall it appears
there's some construction
underway likely maintenance or what
appears to be maintenance
but again this is the busiest section of
the border so far
271 thousand migrants have crossed
through the rio grande
valley now that is about the size the
population size
of madison wisconsin most of the
migrants arrived from the northern
triangle countries say
that they're fleeing poverty and
persecution
tomorrow hhs secretary javier becerra
will visit an emergency
intake site at fort bliss texas it's
currently under the microscope for
reports of poor conditions for children
some of whom are reportedly under
supervision to prevent
self-harm
advocates and the children themselves
have documented inadequate conditions in
that facility and the bind
administration has said that is working
to improve conditions
vice president kamala harris did visit
el paso where she called out the
previous administration for
starting the family separation policy
critics however continued to sound off
about her choice of cities to visit
el paso is a wonderful community it's a
vibrant border community important city
in texas
but it's not the epicenter of the crisis
the epicenter of the crisis as you said
is 800 miles away in the rio grande
valley
now here in the rio grande valley the
threat of course of children harming
themselves
is very real after the journey that they
have been through now among one of those
policies put in place to prevent just
that children usually are asked to
remove
their shoelaces before they're taken
onto a bus and taken to a facility and
of course
counselors at these centers are also
available
eric all right alex on the border
thank you arthel eric president hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else